People that are non-conformist or
otherwise quirky, they constantly are
generating strange ideas on their own.
And if anything, society tells them,
"Hey, like
Like, shut up.
Like, we don't want to hear all your
dumb ideas
on how to make things work better.
Right? That's like like the system
grinds that out of you. Those people
tend to do well with startups because
they don't actually have any problems
coming up with unique ideas.
>> Yes.
>> All right, this is Dalton plus Michael.
And today, we're going to talk about how
to get unique AI startup ideas. Here are
a bunch of old people telling you how to
get unique ideas. Where should we start,
Dalton?
>> I mean, look, the problem right now is
the tools are so good,
>> Yes.
>> you can crank out anything. And so, the
bottleneck is less building the thing,
it's actually um having an idea. And the
problem is most ideas are extremely
non-unique.
>> Yes.
And I would even go so far as to say
many founders out there are not even
being encouraged come up with unique
ideas. Like, they're almost being
encouraged to like
what just raised? What just raised a
seed round? What sounds good to
investors?
Just tell me how I can get funded,
Dalton. Just tell me what idea gets me
funded.
>> almost like whatever the current thing
is on on Twitter. Oh, I guess I'll make
a clone of that. Like, oh, you know,
when we're when we're recording this
right now, it's like, oh, open claw.
Yeah, well, let's just clone that. There
you go, that's my startup. Um
Pretty low effort.
>> Pretty low effort. I think the other
thing that's weird is like when
people who are trying to start companies
think that they can de-risk their idea
by
doing something that they see recently
got funded or they see is like raised a
series B.
Either one of those is really funny.
It's like I've seen so many examples
someone's like, "Well, that thing has
raised money at a billion-dollar
valuation. Therefore, dot dot dot dot
dot."
>> Well, what's so funny is we
inadvertently were part of that problem.
And so, it would always happen when I
was doing interviews for YC is someone I
was interviewing would flag, "Oh, YC
funded a company two batches ago doing
XYZ. So, that validates the market." And
I'd be sitting there being like,
"I funded that company. I did not fund
it for the idea. I actually funded a
different idea and they pivoted during
the batch. And so, as the person who
funded that, this is not validation."
Like, I can't stress enough
as the source
of this validation thing you're talking
about, there's no signal here.
>> You involuntarily validated.
>> Yeah. So, I can't stress enough that
trying to read the tea leaves of what
kind of stuff is launching in the YC
batch,
>> Oh.
>> it's not that it's like exactly wrong,
but it's certainly not
um a marketplace of picking ideas that
have been de-risked.
>> I think it's exactly wrong. I think
they're like like I'm sorry. Like,
you're going to decide on what you're
going to work on for maybe the next 10
to 20 years of your life by looking at a
list of what other people are working
on? Like, come on.
There's certain things that you're
picking that you should think about that
way. Like, maybe where you go to
college. Like, or maybe what you major,
maybe. But like, what you spend the next
20 years of your life on, like, let's
have a little bit more conviction on
that.
>> So, um
one of the ideas that you brought up
that I really like is this idea of
look in the discard bin.
>> Yep.
>> So, so let's talk about that. If if you
shouldn't look at what's cool,
how do you look in the discard bin?
>> Yeah, the way to think about it is
everyone has a filter for startup ideas.
And because we have very similar
filters, if if your if your ideation
process is to find an idea that is both
good and no one's ever thought of it
before, you're going to have a bad time.
You're trying to discover something that
no one has ever thought of before, and
there's a lot of people in the world. I
don't know if you heard Michael, there's
billions of them. And so, most likely
what you actually need to do is to find
an idea that has already been discarded
by others, and it's been discarded for
some reason. Do you get what I'm trying
to say? Like Like instead of trying to
find something no one's ever thought of,
find something that everyone's thought
of and thinks is bad.
>> Yes. Classic examples of that, uh
Instacart would be maybe a very classic
example. One of the things that I see a
lot of people do when they're in this
kind of ideation stage is talk to their
friends and look for things that all of
their friends thinks are good ideas.
>> Yep.
>> And I might advise the exact opposite in
this situation. Like what happens if you
talk to your friends and like you got
maybe not universal bad.
>> What if they told you
>> Yeah, what if they're like, "Look, I'm
worried about you."
If that If you explain your idea
Isn't that Isn't that what happened with
the founders of Airbnb, Michael? Isn't
that the story?
>> It's I would say this.
>> Like their parents were worried about
them.
>> Many successful YC companies, every one
of their friends and family members
thought the idea was bad. We keep on
saying the way you get a unique ideas is
you have to move away from consensus,
right? So we got to move away from the
consensus of startup founders, away from
the consensus of investors, away from
the consensus of your friends.
And
it's really interesting cuz like another
way that I like to think about how to
move away from consensus is
doing things that are just hard. Saying
that you want to do something that takes
10 years, especially when you're a young
person, that just seems really
intimidating. So it's like easy to tell
yourself, "Oh yeah, I know the numbers
say it's going to take 10 years, but
like I'll figure it out in two."
And then you cut down all of the things
that might take longer than two years to
work.
And I feel like
if you want to cheat, just imagine ideas
that might take longer than two years to
work.
And the this is the the the likelihood
of success can be way higher.
>> Yeah. And when you think about examples,
like currently the the consensus is that
being a founder of Open AI and Anthropic
is a good thing. Again, maybe that'll
change.
>> Well, someday.
>> 18 months, right? And when you think
about those companies, A, they were
deeply weird.
>> Yes.
>> Like, can you imagine a weirder start
than how Open AI got started by being a
non-profit research lab and
>> Yeah, during the time of SaaS
ascendance.
>> And
you know, a lot of things didn't go well
and they didn't really have a product
for a long time. Anthropic was like
super weird.
>> Yep.
>> And a lot of their early money came from
FTX. Like the whole story is like
bizarre. And now they seem consensus
very good, but wow,
they're the definition of non-consensus
things.
>> Yes.
>> Right? And so, I'm not even arguing
those are instructive stories that if
you do what they do, you're going to
succeed. I'm actually arguing the
opposite.
Which is
trying to just copy what worked in the
past for other people isn't necessarily
going to give you a truly unique idea.
>> One of the things that actually makes
this harder
is how much content VCs are putting out
there.
>> Yep.
>> If you're a young founder in the early
2000s, how much VC content did you have
access to?
>> It didn't exist, right? So, the way it
worked is before TechCrunch, the only
people that wrote about technology were
like the Wall Street Journal,
>> Walt Mossberg.
>> And he would mostly cover Apple.
>> Yeah.
>> He'd be talking about the new Mac or
whatever.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, if you were a startup, there was
nowhere
>> CES.
>> Yeah, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Um
And so, then TechCrunch came out and it
was the first place to like cover
startups. And then now we have this
like, you know,
we have a lot of content out there. And
again, I'm, you know, we are certainly
part of it. And I realize that our
voices have been part of this thing.
>> Yes.
>> My justification is that we've never
tried to explicitly tell founders what
to think.
More
kind of just giving telling stories,
giving advice, kind of like we're doing
office hours, but with a wider group of
people.
>> Yes.
>> But if you're making all of your life
decisions based on podcasts, that is a
definition of coming up with ideas that
are not unique.
>> Yeah.
>> Like literally that's the definition of
a non-unique idea is something that you
heard in a podcast, right?
>> Yeah.
>> There's a trope around startup ideas
that have been around the entire time
that we've been doing startups that I
might argue
wasn't followed during the B2B SaaS era.
This idea of solving your own problem or
being your own user. It's interesting
now because it almost seems like this is
completely gone out of style.
This idea that like, oh, if I'm working
on something for myself, there's no way
it can get big or like there's no way
the market's big enough or like why why
I don't trust my own ability
>> to like Yeah. choose things. How do you
think about this?
>> I think one of the big talking points on
on, you know, VC podcasts or VC content
is
hey, $100 billion outcomes, trillion
dollar outcomes are the only things that
matter. And if it doesn't seem really
big, it's not even it's like a joke.
You'd like
You'd like mock someone who
And so
what that's causing is a lot of ideas
that are like truly unique, wouldn't
ever fit within that framework. And so
of course the example, you know, your
startup uh Justin putting the camera on
his head to start Twitch
>> Doesn't work.
>> That's Is that a $100 billion
opportunity, Michael?
Like you would filter that out.
>> Yes.
>> Right?
>> Something like Whatnot, which is, you
know, one of my better investments at
YC. It's like, okay, so it's a
marketplace for authenticated Funko
Pops. What's the TAM on that?
>> Yeah.
>> You would discard that.
>> And so I think trying to take these like
late-stage
investor advice things and apply them to
startup ideas, only a small number of
things would meet that bar. Mhm. And so
you're going to end up with extremely
derivative repetitive ideas that would
meet that bar.
>> I completely agree. And I think this
leads me to my last thought on the
subject, which is I have found that
sometimes weird people have an easier
time coming up with weird aka unique
ideas. We do have this challenge that
now that tech seems like such a money
maker and there's so much money invested
in early stage startups, there are a lot
of people who are not very weird, who
are very attracted to this space. It's
funny that I'm saying weird is like a
positive because I think in the normal
context in America, weird isn't seen as
positive, but like
a lot of these ideas that worked seemed
really weird and a lot of the people,
when you know them,
yeah, are a little weird. So like how do
you think about
you know, I sometimes wonder is the tech
startup world as welcoming to weird
people as it once was?
>> Yeah.
>> How do you think about this?
>> I think it's a great point. And again,
maybe this is just, you know, we're
getting old or something. That's That's
an option, but people that are
non-conformist or otherwise quirky in
ways that you would describe as
Uh quirky is the nice way to say it, but
like like it
they they tend to do their own weird
stuff and they don't usually need to ask
permission. Like they they constantly
are generating strange ideas on their
own. And if anything, society tells
them, "Hey, like
like shut up.
Like we don't want to hear all your dumb
ideas
on how to make things work better.
Right? That's like like the system
grinds that out of you. Those people
tend to do well with startups because
they don't actually have any problems
coming up with unique ideas.
>> Yes.
>> Probably their bigger problem is
filtering out deciding which unique idea
is worth their time cuz they're always
coming up with ideas.
>> Yes.
>> Versus a lot of systems are consensus
machines
>> Yes.
>> and people that are really good at
calibrating and triangulating consensus,
those tend to be people that have the
hardest time coming up with unique ideas
cuz it's sort of been beaten out of them
and it's just not their natural
thing. Like again, in the in the example
of like Y Combinator itself,
most investors that start funds have
investment experience
>> Mhm.
>> and have a career where they're like,
"Oh, I have a Harvard MBA or a Stanford
MBA and then I worked here as an
associate and then
>> Yeah.
>> And like Paul Graham was like, "I built
a Lisp website
and I got rich and I decided to do this
really weird thing that I made up from
first principles of letting young people
apply to a summer program
>> Yeah.
>> and as it turns out, that's the guy that
all these like normie VCs like look up
to
>> Yep.
>> and he's just like a weird guy
>> guy.
>> who had no um training.
>> Yeah.
>> And did something that
would never have been produced by by
like a normal investor, right?
>> Well, to take it a step further,
made something that he wished existed
when he was a founder.
>> Yeah.
>> Like made something that he would have
appealed to him.
So, it's tricky cuz I think that like,
you know, there are a lot of people who
are watching this video who are probably
thinking, "Is the startup world right
for me?" I find it awkward to say that
like even though this is an exciting
time for tech,
not everyone is cut out for this.
>> Yeah.
>> Not everyone is cut out to be the person
coming up with the idea. I don't know.
What What should you do if you're having
too hard of a problem?
>> If it's your dream,
you should totally try to start a
company and I would never I would feel
really bad if I ever said something that
made people
question themselves or feel bad in these
videos we're making cuz we're making
them because we're trying to to help
people, but if you really really really
struggle to come up with unique ideas,
>> Yeah.
>> it's totally okay to go work somewhere.
>> Fair.
>> Like and you still get to be part of
>> That's true.
>> You still get to be part of things.
Like, not everyone has to
be like a weird shaman that comes up
with strange ideas. Like, it's okay.
And when you think about it, society
wouldn't work if if everyone like
thought that way.
>> Well, I love that point cuz also
maybe you should work with someone who's
weird.
>> Yeah.
>> And they should come up with the idea. I
mean, that's that's what I did.
>> That's true. You just kind of went along
for the ride for the on the ideation
part.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> That's what you guys want to do.
>> Yeah. I would have not helped in the
ideation process of putting a camera on
Justin's head.
contributed at all. So, you can work
somewhere, you can join with someone.
This is maybe an interesting point.
Like, everyone interested in startups
doesn't have to be the person who comes
up with the idea.
>> Yeah.
>> I think that like, in closing for me, um
it is hard to feel like you're working
on something
where a lot of people think it's a bad
idea.
That's hard.
And I like talking about this because
you should brace yourself for that.
Like, that is 100% the experience of
everyone that's succeeded.
So, it's like
So, like I know it's hard, right? But,
like
you should feel
like you're there.
And you should feel maybe like you're
going to be there for a couple years.
And like, if you're working on something
that you're so excited by, you're
willing to be there for a couple years.
>> As someone who funds startup founders, I
am excited by that, right?
When I meet someone who I get the vibe,
if this doesn't work in a couple months
they're moving along. I I'm always like,
oh.
>> Yeah. I don't you know, I always had
this phrase. It's like,
you're 10% in, but you want me to be
100% in? Like, that's like a weird
So, I don't know. So, for for for the
people watching, like, it's totally cool
to be weird and to work on something
people think is weird. If you're going
to use it, including us. Like basically
like if your filter is do the people on
the on these videos seem like they'd
approve of our ideas, we're saying no.
Like don't be approval seeking from
authority figures if you want actually
have unique ideas. Well, and I'll extend
that further. We have regularly funded
ideas that we thought were bad.
We have regularly worked with founders
who pitched ideas that we thought were
bad. And like to be completely honest,
like sometimes I think of my job is like
I'm a doctor. I'm treating the patient
walking in the door. I don't get to
choose. Like I want to help these folks
succeed and who am I to know whether
this is going to work? Yep. I'm not
going to, you know, let's not put
ourselves in that position. Anyways,
great chat, Dalton. All right, thanks.